and two the direct acknowledgement that you have
hurt people around you and i mean you know there's
not really that it's like i've alarmed and i've
upset people with my behavior it to me reads yeah
it's a very sort of insular statement it's more
about me than it is about anybody else out there
and yeah i'm sorry if i upset or alarmed
you if i caused you some kind of emotional
distress in reacting to me but not i'm sorry for
the people i hurt or endangered or whatever else
what is going on there citizens of
the reject nation greg here today
john how are you i am very anticipated what we're
about to talk about so we were out and about this
news dropped as we were on our way back and i
was like well well we have some thoughts already
we gotta talk about it you knew we would ezra
miller this sounds like a publicist statement
in all honesty probably is ezra miller has
issued a statement to variety here's how it goes
having recently gone through a time of crisis on
infinite earth through a time of intense crisis
i now understand that i am suffering complex
mental health issues and have begun ongoing
treatment i want to apologize to everyone that
i have alarmed and upset with my past behavior
you know when you like read it like i heard it
on the road and then you read it it just i am
committed to doing the necessary work to get back
to a healthy safe and productive stage in my life
i'm very apprehensive towards the statement
because yeah i mean i think all of us
would more than likely agree most of us
even the ones who would say uh you know
who are the ones who are for ezra miller i think
there's no denying that there is a mental health
issues that definitely need to be worked on that
definitely need to be treated that there has to
be something for it so at least they're owning up
to that right it's just there's some specifically
calculated words because it's still not about
owning up to the past actions just saying that
when you take the time especially to issue
a statement one working with the publicist
you one would assume that if they really
did feel responsible for their actions
or that they did do something wrong they
would might actually be a little bit more
forthcoming with saying that i know that sounds
presumptuous so i'm sure there's more to actually
come out the reason why i'm going with there
with that mentality is because of the fact that
just because someone has mental health issues
doesn't mean there shouldn't be consequences for
one's actions like yes they should go get mental
health treatment sure at the same time punishment
should be dealt in some fashion everything with
dakota iron irons that we learned of what started
at the age of 12 i think that in itself is a
terrible thing that the amount of reports of
like terrorizing hawaii whether a fraction of them
were were not true or were who knows bottom line
is like you know that some of this is true to say
the least there are enough events at least some
of them have to be authentic and i think that it
doesn't matter if you you have just mental health
issues or not like there should be consequences
for that because bottom line is this individual
is more likely to get off the hook due to the
fact of their power and fame and they should
not be able to get off the hook due to their power
and fame while one can read this and interpret it
like oh they must be owning up they're technically
not owning up to the things they have actually
done i'm really not trying to be mr dramatic about
it i'm really not because if they did i'd be like
oh well at least i owned up i still think there's
got to be consequences this seems very calculated
in the specific word choices it does it does it's
one of those things where you know my initial
reaction is i want to believe this is true i wanna
put the best you know faith in people and i don't
know because yeah this is very well packaged it's
very sort of conscientious in how it is worded you
i don't wanna be so cynical but this says in
the article that a representative of the actor
sent this statement in so i gotta imagine this
may have been workshopped with a few people it's
hard because i can understand why somebody would
be inclined to accept this but there also yeah
isn't a naming of the specific past behaviors that
they want to own up to or what specific kind of
treatment is and hey they don't have to give they
don't owe us all of their intimate medical details
of course and it's good that they're seeking
treatment and all that other stuff but yeah i
mean it does read as a bit of a gloss just to be
like hey sorry to anybody alarmed with my past
behavior moving right on past that i feel like
yeah this is probably a bid in a lot of ways to
maintain as little disruption of ezra miller's
status at the moment as possible and i think
what you said is absolutely true i wish this
came with maybe a pledge to take some time away
from the public eye or to take some time away
from everything to really go and do the work
acknowledge what the work is not only on the
personal side getting treatment that's great yes
but also you know how are you going to kind of
at least address and or atone for these strange
occurrences that you've been putting people
through across the country so yeah it reads is a
bit clean while i really hope the work is getting
done there's not really a specific acknowledgement
of that stuff here so i i don't know i don't know
how much i'll wait and see ezra miller shouldn't
be at the same status they are right now while
they're taking care of this issue i feel like they
should take all that time to do the personal and
external work and then maybe come back into the
to the acting world or whatever not that this is
really necessarily commenting on their career in
particular but you know that's why the statement
is here you know at least they're aware of
some of the damages that have actually been
happening and it sounds like the pressure's
been cooking like it's really interesting that you
know that whole felony burglary charge comes out
i did see on social media that there were people
going that there was some other neighbor if i'm
not mistaken please feel free to add on in the
comments if i am incorrectly uh remembering this
but i believe there were some other neighborhoods
like this would just go over there all the time
they would borrow from each other this whole
story is getting blown out of proportion
and that's not exactly how it is maybe if it's the
same time there's still a felony burglary charge
it seems like there's always some
defense you shouldn't have to break
done for all that's like all the more reason
you should have to break in then if you have
that well of a rapport with somebody then it would
stand a reason they would just allow you to access
it and then while there was like that charge
and then of course warner brothers with the the
reported uh three options they have for ezra
miller like this looks like it's going down option
numero uno right here of what they would want
ezra to do it's very easy to be calculated and
manipulative with your wording though situations
like this i'm like this is like a a thing that has
to really be out there not just with your words
like clarity specificity with your words but also
actions that follow forward you know and time
yeah you know and two the direct acknowledgement
that you have hurt people around you and i
mean you know but there's not really that it's
like i've alarmed and i've upset people with my
behavior it to me reads yeah it's a very sort
of insular statement it's more about me than
it is about anybody else out there and yeah
i'm sorry if i upset or alarmed you if i caused
you some kind of emotional distress in reacting
to me but not i'm sorry for the people i hurt or
endangered or whatever else yeah so that's pretty
much where we're coming from on the matter
i hope that the people who are legitimately
harmed post-actions can find some type of resolve
and resolution hope that the treatment goes well
for ezra miller for the future and we're one
step closer to seeing the flash one step closer
damage control damage control get this [__]
under control yeah no i wouldn't i wouldn't
be surprised if somebody made a few calls and
threatened no you know like the fact that ezra's
finally speaking it doesn't seem coincidental at
all it's like oh this is all really lining up with
everything we've been hearing reported on yeah
and a weird time to drop the information yeah like
evening and los angeles yeah weird timing yeah
all right guys well what do you think about this
uh leave your thoughts down below my hair has been
in my eyes this whole time apologies see you soon
you